الاسرائيلي فجر اليوم بالقراءه الاولى على
احد اهم التعديلات التي اقترحتها حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو على النظام القضائي في
اسرائيل الذي يتيح للسلطه التشريعيه
التغلب على قرارات المحكمه العليا ومنعها
من الغاء قوانين يسنها الكنيست ويشترط
التعديل لقاء ذلك اغلبيه اربعه اخماس قضاه
المحكمه في اي تشكيله كما يمنح القانون
الكنيست القوه لتحصين اي قانون في وجه
المحكمه كما يمنح اعضاء الكنيست الحق في
اعاده تشريع اي قانون تلغيه المحكمه
العليا اذا ما حظي باغلبيه 61 عضو احتاج
هذا التعديل الى التصديق عليه بالقراءتين
الثانيه والثالثه حتى يصبح نافذا
من جهه اخرى صدق الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
بالقراءه الاولى وباغلبيه 61 صوتا على
تعديل قانوني يمنع تنحيه رئيس الحكومه من
منصبه الا وفق اسباب نفسيه او مرضيه شرط
ان يحظى ذلك باغلبيه 90 عضوا من الكنيست
من اصل مئه وعشرين وعمل الائتلاف الحاكم
على ادخال هذا التعديل من اجل منع
المستشاره القانونيه للحكومه اجباري
بنيامين تنياهو على التنحي من منصبه بسبب
ما يلاحقه من قضايا فسد
وكان الرئيس الاسرائيلي يسحاق هرتز سوق قد
قال ان اسرائيل تمر بوضع خطير جدا قد تكون
له تبعات على سياسه والاقتصاد والمجتمع
والامن في البلاد وبشان استمرار
الاحتجاجات المناهضه لسعي الحكومه لتعديل
بعض القوانين المتعلقه بالقضاء وتقليص
صلاحيات المحكمه العليا قال الرئيس
الاسرائيلي انه يبذل جهودا مضنيه للتوصل
الى صيغه تسويه مقبوله للائتلاف والمعارضه
اجل انقاذ اسرائيل وتحصين اساسها لاجيال
قادمه من جانبها قالت رئيسه المحكمه
العليا السابقه انما يجري من تشريعات يضعف
جهاز القضائي وحماته ويدخل الدوله في ازمه
لم تعهدها من قبل
[موسيقى]
من القدس ينضم الينا مراسلنا الياس كرام
الياس عن هذه التعديلات التي صدق عليها
الكنيست بالقراءه الاولى
وفرص مضيئه الى الاقرار النهائي
بالفعل الائتلاف الحاكم في اسرائيل يخطو
خطا حديثا هذا اليوم باتجاه ما يقول بانها
اصلاحات
قانونيه او اصلاحات في جهاز القضاء والتي
تصفها المعارضه الاسرائيليه بانها انقلاب
على نظام الحكم في اسرائيل وتقليص صلاحيات
المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه هذا المشروع القانون الذي تم
التصديق عليه فجر هذا اليوم بالقراءه
الاولى بطبيعه الحال يحتاج الى مزيد من
المناقشات في لجنه الدستور والقضاء
البرلمانيه قبل عرضه مره اخرى على الهيئه
العامه للكنيست من اجل التصديق عليه
بالقراءتين الثانيه والثالثه ليصبح قانونا
نافذه لكن هذا احد اهم التعديلات
القانونيه التي تحاول
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تمريرها في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي وهي تقليص صلاحيات المحكمه
العليا في الغاء قوانين يشرعها الكنيست
وتحسين بعض القوانين في وجه المحكمه
العليا من الغائها
وبطبيعه الحال الحكومه الاسرائيليه كانت
صدقت ايضا او الكنيست صدق في الاسابيع
الماضيه على مشروعي قانون اخر يمنح
الائتلاف الحاكم في اسرائيل الاغلبيه في
لجنه تعيين القضاه بحيث ان تكون الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لها الغلبه في تحديد شكل
القضاه ومن يتولون القضاه في المحاكم
الاسرائيليه وتحديدا في المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه هذا بالاضافه الى سلسله
قوانين اخرى تاتي في اطار هذا الانقلاب
على النظام القضائي في اسرائيل واحد اهمها
هو بطبيعه الحال التعديل الذي ادخل على
قانون اساس الحكومه والذي يمنع من تنحيه
رئيس الحكومه لاسباب سياسيه او لاسباب
قضائيه وهو يحدد ان عمليه التنحيه تتم فقط
فيما اذا كان يعاني من حالات مرضيه او من
حاله نفسيه تقول دون ان يقوم بمهام منصبه
على اكمل
الوجه وهذا القانون كان يهدف من وراء ذلك
منع المستشار القضائيه للحكومه من تنحيه
اليمين نتنياهو عن السلطه بسبب ما يلحقه
من تهم الفساد بالاضافه الى قوانين اخرى
تحاول الحكومه اقراها وتمنع ايضا المحكمه
العليا من التدخل في تعيينات الوزراء
لاتاحه المجال امام عوده وزراء مدنين
بقضايا جنائيه الى طاوله الحكومه شكرا
جزيلا لك الياس كرام مراسلنا من القدس